Mhm.
Okay.
Uh I was just noticing that on Twitch
there's a little icon uh that uh says
excellent and I think it means that the
the stream quality is excellent. Uh so I
don't know I mean it's possible that
watching on Twitch is better than
watching on Zoom. I don't know.
Uh
Right, yeah. And and perhaps uh OBS is
taking priority over Zoom. Uh
Mhm.
All right, well, let's get started.
Uh so uh
So today uh we're going to pick up where
we left off last time. Uh last time
well, so last week uh
was week one, right? Uh we began talking
about what distributed systems are and
then we began talking about this notion
of happens before. Uh and we began to
talk uh
on Friday about how happens before is a
is a partial order and particularly it's
this this special kind of partial order,
an irreflexive partial order.
Uh so um
Uh let's let's recap a little bit from
last time. I realized that uh we had a
couple of quiz questions last week and
uh I never talked about what the answers
to those quiz questions are. Uh so we
can do that now. Um so
um
So let's let's look at what the quiz
questions were uh last week.
Um so
We had a quiz every day last week
actually, but Monday uh Monday the quiz
was just a survey about uh office hours.
So uh so this is the first content quiz
question that we had, which is what is a
distributed system? Um so I said uh pick
whichever, you know, pick uh Martin
Kleppmann's definition, which we talked
about, or pick Peter Alvaro's
definition, which we talked about, um
or uh or or uh your own interpretation.
So um
Well, so so
what I was amused by in this is that
some people answered the question by
just writing like Peter Alvaro's
definition instead of actually defining
uh it. Uh and some people, at least one
person just wrote Peter Alvaro. Like the
definition of a distributed system is
Peter Alvaro. Okay. Um but what I was
actually going for here was for you to
actually uh to write down the
definition. Um so the the the Kleppmann
definition is a distributed system is uh
some uh collection of nodes connected by
a network uh that is uh
and a node in this case could be thought
of as a computer or maybe as some
software running on a computer.
Uh so some collection of nodes connected
by a network and characterized by
partial failure.
Um so that was the Kleppmann definition
uh which I like a lot. Peter's
definition is a distributed system is a
system that experiences both partial
failure and unbounded latency. So
unbounded latency is also a key piece of
it. Um at least from our point of view.
Uh so that's that's what we uh we're
going for uh with this question or some
combination of those things or something
that hit that highlighted the points
that we discussed. Mostly uh that
there's more than one computer involved
uh and that failure is involved.
Um then the other quiz question, which
was from Friday, is we said, "Okay, so
if if you have two events A and B, um we
say A happened before B under what
circumstances?" And so there should have
been three parts to this, uh the three
parts of of the definition of the
happens before relation. Um
First part was uh if A happens before B
on the same process, then we say A
happens before B. Uh a process is
inherently single-threaded, we say. So
if A happens before B in in a given
process, then then A definitely happens
before B. Uh another way for A happen to
be A to happen before B is if A is a
message send and B is a message receive.
Uh a message can't be sent after it's
received. Uh
So if A is a send and B is the
corresponding receive, then we say A
happened before B. And then the third
part of the definition uh
is uh is the piece that makes it uh
transitive. So we say, "Well, if you
have some other event C and we know that
A happened before C and we know that C
happened before B, then we can put those
together to say, 'Okay, we know A
happened before B.'" Uh and the
combination of these uh three pieces
allows us to look at some large
collection of events that happen on many
processes that are communicating with
each other via sends and receives and um
and come up uh with an overall picture
of what we know happened before what.
Um so that those were the the quiz
questions last time. Um
We'll continue uh with this quiz
approach and have another quiz question
today.
Um but let's let's go on and talk about
today's uh topic.
Um
So um
Okay, so so we just recapped uh the
definition of of the happens before
relation. Uh and and we talked about how
uh last time the happens before relation
is is a special kind of of um
of of partial order um which is which is
an irreflexive partial order. Um so
the happens before relation, we uh
there's these three parts to it. Um if A
happens before B on the same process
line or if A is a send and B is a
receive, then A happens before B or
if those things are put together
somehow.
Then those are all situations where um
where where we know A happens before B.
Uh and this um
And and so the set of all of the events
in a system um there could be lots of
other events uh
here too. Uh the the set of all of the
events in the system um are are ordered
by this partial order. Uh
but the happens before order is is a
slightly weird partial order in that
it's it's not uh
it it doesn't it doesn't have what we
call reflexivity. Um so a traditional or
or a standard partial order
uh has these properties that it's
reflexive
uh which means that uh
for all um
uh so if it's a partial order of of um
let's say it's a set S
um
uh together with a binary relation
that looks like this.
So we're going to say um for all
A that is a member of S
um reflexivity would say that A is less
than or equal to A.
Uh antisymmetry
would say that
for all A and B in the set S
if A is less than or equal to B
and B is less than or equal to A
then
A and B have to be the same.
And then the last bit is uh transitive.
Which says that
for all A, B, and C in S
if A is related to B in this way
and I should have an if here also.
And B is related to C
then A
is related to C.
Um so those are the properties that are
true of of of a partial order typically.
Um but for uh for but for this
particular partial order, the happens
before relation, um it's not quite one
of these partial orders because it
doesn't have this reflexivity property.
Uh
because it wouldn't make sense in this
case because we would be saying that for
all instead of
So substituting in what we're talking
about here, we're talking about events
in this set of events, uh we would say
for all events every event happens
before itself. And so we don't want to
say that. And so uh this this is
actually not a true partial order. It's
instead what we call an irreflexive
partial order.
So these properties are true for the
happens before relation, but but uh
reflexivity is not.
Um so you'll you'll often hear people
hear people, including me, say, "This is
a partial order."
Uh so I'm letting you know that you
don't have to say, "Well, actually, it's
an irreflexive partial order." Uh it's
fine to just say partial order, right?
People will probably know what you mean.
Um but what's an example of a of a of a
partial order that that actually is a a
true partial order? Um
So so here's one.
Uh so
so set containment
or set inclusion
as it's sometimes called. So So in this
case, um so again, a partial order is
it's a set together
uh with a binary relation.
So the set in this case
is going to be
all subsets of a set. For instance,
um let's say that we have the set
ABC.
And these are just any ABC, uh anything.
Um
So So we could write down the set of all
subsets of this.
Um so what's the set of all subsets of
ABC?
Uh well, it would have to include the
empty set, right?
Um and then the set with just A,
the set with just B,
the set with just C,
the set of A and B,
A and C,
uh B and C,
and then all three.
So there should be eight of them. 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8. Um so this uh this set S has
eight elements
uh which can be ordered by set inclusion
um or this relation.
Um and so we can draw a picture of how
those eight sets are related, um putting
the empty set at the bottom
and putting this set ABC at the top.
So then
well
what sets are are
uh the empty set contained in? Well,
the empty set is contained in
everything.
Um
but we can put at the bottom these three
singleton sets A, B, and C,
the set containing A, the set containing
B, and the set containing C.
And then one step up from that, we have
all the sets that have two elements in
them.
So the set containing A is a subset of
the set containing A and B, so I can
draw a line from here to there.
Um the set containing B is also a subset
of the set containing A and B, so I can
do a line there.
And similarly, I can do a line from
the set containing A to the set
containing A and C, and then like this,
and then like this,
and then of course, all three of those
are
subsets of the set
containing A, B, and C. Um so we have
this nifty lattice here,
uh which is a kind of a visual depiction
of the of the um of the set uh
containment relation.
Uh so this is an example of uh
of a partial order that really is uh uh
truly a partial order, uh as in it
actually uh it actually checks all the
checkboxes, so it is reflexive.
Um because like say, if you wanted to
know uh
is this set A
a subset or equal to
this set containing A? Well, the answer
is yes.
Um
so and then that's true for any uh if
you pick any element of this set S and
you ask, is this is it a subset to or
equal to itself? Uh the answer will be
yes. Um and then the other two
properties um
of antisymmetry
uh
and transitivity
they both hold as well. Um so we're not
going to go to the trouble of um
uh of proving that, um but it's true. Um
so somebody in in chat asks um how does
the set containing A uh relate to the
the set uh containing B and C? Yeah, so
good question. So they're not related by
the partial order.
Um so a partial order doesn't
necessarily relate every element in this
set S to every other element in this
set. Um that's kind of the point, in
fact. Um some things aren't related. So
um so it so so those two are not related
by this particular order. Maybe you
could come up with some other order uh
that related them, I don't know. Um but
this set inclusion order doesn't relate
them.
Uh so that's a that's an example of a
partial order. Now, some orders are
total orders, which mean that you can
That means that you can compare every
two elements in them.
Uh so what's an example of a total
order? What's like a really What's the
What's the simplest total order that you
can think of?
Or what's one that comes up a lot in
everyday life?
The integers. All right, so somebody
suggests the integers or even like the
natural numbers, right? Um so yeah,
okay, let's go with let's go with the
integers. So
um
well, let's say let's stick with the
natural numbers just cuz I want to have
a a a a smallest one.
Um so
So in this case, our set S is just the
natural numbers, right? And the
uh relation
we can just say is the usual less than
or equal uh
relation on the partial or
relation on on the natural numbers. So
then our picture
is just going to be a straight line,
right?
And goes on forever like that. Notice
how before, this picture
uh
wasn't just one straight line, right? We
had this this lattice shape. Um
and now we have a straight line because
uh the natural numbers are totally
ordered. Um
And so every natural number is
comparable to every other natural
number. So that's a total order.
Um so
that's probably all about all I have to
say about that right now. Um if this
were a class about order theory, we
could we could go into a lot more
detail, um but this is a class about
distributed systems.
So
um let's come back to
uh let's come back to to happens before.
So
we said that there were these three
pieces of the of the definition of the
happens before relation, right? Um let's
let's just write them down one more time
visually.
Um
so
one event happens before another on the
same process line,
or if an event is a send and then it
happens before its corresponding
receive,
or there's transitivity that can put
those pieces together.
Okay.
So if you've got a bunch of events,
you can use this definition to figure
out you know, what happened before what.
Or at least you could if you had an
efficient way to compute what is in the
happens before relation.
So what we talked about uh previously,
uh
we we looked at a set of events and we
sort of computed by hand what was in the
happens before relation uh for that
particular set of events by just kind of
looking at it.
Um
so uh but but what we want to do is
actually come up with an with an
algorithm uh
by which a computer can can
straightforwardly compute what's in the
happens before relation. And this leads
into our next topic. Um
So last week we talked about clocks. Uh
in particular, we mentioned a couple of
different kinds of physical clocks, um
but we also talked about problems with
using physical clocks.
Um so what did what did we say the
alternative to using physical clocks
was?
Logical clocks. Yeah, so this is this is
an entirely different notion of clock.
Uh logical clocks don't tell us anything
about the time of day, and they don't
tell us anything about time elapsed. Uh
instead, logical clocks only tell us
about the ordering of events.
So the simplest kind of of logical clock
that I am aware of is called a Lamport
clock.
And a Lamport clock
is just a way of assigning numbers to
events.
So if you have an event, let's say event
A,
um
then
its Lamport clock,
um which we write LC of A,
it might be three, for instance.
So what do these Lamport clocks mean?
Like what does that number three tell
you?
Well, here's a rule.
We know that
if A happens before B,
then
the Lamport clock of A
is less than the Lamport clock of B.
So, we say that Lamport clocks
are
consistent with
causality.
That means that if there's a causal
relationship between A and B,
um or a potentially causal relationship
between A and B, that is if A happens
before B,
then we know that the Lamport clock of A
is going to be less than the Lamport
clock of B.
Um so, we're going to uh so, we're going
to write down uh
the rules for assigning Lamport clocks
to events. Uh so, let's put some events
down and then just try to assign Lamport
clocks to them.
So, here's some events.
All right.
So, here's
the algorithm for assigning Lamport
clocks to events.
First of all,
every process has a counter that's
initialized to zero, an integer counter
or natural number counter.
On every event,
a process will increment its counter by
one.
I'll go over here to write down rule
three.
Rule three is what you do when you send
a message.
When sending a message,
a process
includes
its current counter along with the
message.
And step four is what you do when
receiving a message.
This is the interesting part. Uh what do
you think happens here? What do you
think you do when you receive a message?
Yeah, so there's some good suggestions
in chat. Uh like take the maximum of the
received counter and your own counter.
Yeah, so what you're going to do is
set your counter
to the max
of your local
counter
and the message counter
plus one.
So, recall that that sending and
receiving are are both considered
events.
Yes.
So, um
by the way, um in some formulations of
this algorithm,
message receives don't get counted as
events. Um
so, if you don't count message receives
as events, you wouldn't have to do this
plus one here.
Uh so, if you've seen this before and it
didn't have the plus one, then that's
why.
That might be why.
Um but we are going to be treating
message receives as events for now.
Later in the course, we might look at a
scenario where message receives don't
count as an events as events, but um and
that's something when you're when you're
talking about events, step one step
zero, right, is to decide what counts as
an event. Uh and that can be
up to you, right? Uh so, it can depend
really what you're trying to to
accomplish. Um but for us right now,
we're counting both message sends and
receives as events.
Um
So,
um
we have a way of assigning numbers to
events now. Uh so, let's try it.
Um so, we have to give every process a
counter, right? Um so, it's going to
start out at zero for every one of
these.
Okay.
So,
we say on every event, a process
increments its counter. That's the rule.
Um
So, um
what
does the counter become for this uh for
this event here? Let's Let's say Let's
call these processes A, B, and C just to
give them names.
Um so, on process A, we have an event
here. It's a message send. Um what
should happen there?
Yeah, so this would be this becomes one
right here.
All right.
So, here's a receive. So, process B is
receiving a message right here. Process
is B Process B's local counter is
currently zero. Um but this this number
one got sent along
uh with the message. So, you can imagine
this message uh kind of consisting of
two parts, right? Uh one of those parts
is going to be you could call it the
payload, right, the part that is
actually the reason why a message is is
getting sent.
And then the other part, you could call
it the metadata, uh which is some
additional data that accompanies the
message. And in this case, the
additional data that's accompanying the
message is just this number one.
Um so, the one shows up here.
We take the maximum, right, of the local
counter, which is zero, and the message
counter, which is one.
And the maximum of zero and one, of
course, is is one. Um and then we have
to add one to that. So, the the counter
here becomes two.
Um
So, then
um
we've got a another message sent.
Um
So, also this this up here is going to
change. I should I should have pointed
out. This is going to This counter up
here for for process A is going to
increment to one. So, now this process's
local clock is one. This one's changes
changes to two.
Um
So, now we have a message send here. Um
so, so what happens on a send?
Or what is our uh
what is our clock number now?
It should be three. That's right. So,
this is three.
And this changes to three up here.
The three gets sent along with this
message over to process C.
Now,
we've received a message here on process
C.
Um what takes place there? Well,
three is the number arriving on the
message counter. Zero is the the value
of the local counter. The maximum of
those is three.
Um so, we set our counter to the maximum
of those plus one.
So, that's four.
Then here we have another message send.
Uh so, this uh
this message send, we have to increment
um
our counter because that's an event,
right? So, we have to we have to
increment our counter.
And the five gets sent along here.
Finally, we arrive over here at process
A again.
Um we compare our local counter, which
is at one, to the message counter, which
is at five. The maximum is going to be
five, and we add one to that, so the the
value of this uh
um
or the clock, the Lamport clock of this
event becomes six.
So,
if you walk through and look at the
Lamport clocks here, um
you'll see that this this condition that
we wrote down before uh is in fact true.
So, if A happens before B, then the
Lamport clock of A is indeed going to be
less than the Lamport clock of B.
Um
this was a pretty simple one.
but what about the other way around?
Um
so, so we know that
uh
we know
that
if A
happens before B,
then
Lamport clock of Oops, that should just
be less than.
LC of A is less than LC of B.
Um
so, in other words, Lamport clocks are
consistent with causality. That's what
we said.
But what about the other way around? So,
if LC of A
is less than LC of B,
do we know that A happened before B?
So, here's the last uh
the the
somebody was asking to see this again.
So, um here's here's the
previous slide again, and I'm going to
take a picture of it right now.
All right.
So, back to that question.
So, we know if A happens before B, then
the Lamport clock of A will be less than
the Lamport clock of B.
But
if the Lamport clock of A is less than
the Lamport clock of B, do we know that
A happened before B? What do you think?
Yeah, perhaps surprisingly, it turns out
that that the answer is no. Um so, let's
look at an example of that.
Um
so, let's say that we have um processes
Let's say
P1, P2, and P3.
Um and let's let's put some events up
here.
Um
so, let's say
call this event A.
Okay, and let's call this one event B
here.
So, let's let's try to assign Lamport
clocks to these events.
Um let's just see if we can do it. Um
so,
every process starts out with its uh
Lamport clock at zero.
All right.
So, we have an event A here. Um this one
isn't a message send or a receive, it's
just an internal event. Um
but uh but we're going to uh we're going
to count those, too. Those count as
events. So, um so, the Lamport clock
here is one.
Then here's an event, right, on process
two.
Um well, what's what's the Lamport clock
of this event going to be?
Great, that one's also going to be one.
So, the number one is going to get sent
along uh on this message as metadata.
And it comes over here to process three,
where the the current uh process clock
is zero. The one and the zero are going
to get compared. One is bigger, uh so,
we'll take the maximum of the two, which
is one, and then this clock over here is
going to become two.
Then we have another event. Uh happens
to be a message send, and because it's
an event, we increment our clock.
So, that's going to The clock there is
going to become three.
The three is going to get sent along
with the message.
Uh and we arrive over here.
We compare the three to uh to our
current process clock uh over here,
which is one. Uh three is bigger than
one.
So, three is going to be the maximum.
Uh and then we add one to that, so the
clock here becomes four.
This should have been changed to three
over here.
Um then we have another internal event
here. So, the clock here is going to be
five.
Let's come back over here.
So, on process three,
uh we're here.
We want to figure out what the clock
value of this event is.
Uh our current local clock is three,
and we increment every time we have an
event.
So, the clock there becomes four.
Four gets sent along this message here.
Four gets compared with the local clock
here, which was one. Four is bigger than
one.
So, the maximum of the two is four, and
we add one to that, so the clock here is
five.
Then finally, we have this event down
here.
Happens to be a message send. We
increment every time there's an event,
and a message send is certainly an
event, so our clock here is six.
Six gets sent along with the message.
And down here, six gets compared with uh
the current process clock here.
Uh
updating my process clocks.
six gets compared with five.
Six is bigger than five, and so the
maximum of the two is six, and one gets
added to that, so the clock here becomes
seven.
So,
the two events that I kind of pointed
out originally were events A
and B here.
So, in this picture,
A has a clock value, a Lamport clock
value of only one.
Uh uh so, there's a great question in
chat, which is, do we increment the
counter if an event fails? Uh so, we
actually haven't started talking about
failure at all yet. Um but also, uh
I don't know what you mean by an event
fails. So, when we start to talk about
failure, uh we'll talk about uh
what kinds of failures can occur.
Uh so, a failure could include a process
crashing.
Uh that's one kind of failure that we'll
talk about. Um but another kind of
failure we'll talk about uh is um
messages getting lost. Um so, yeah, I
mean, if you don't if you don't receive
a message, right, then that event never
happened as far as you're concerned,
right? Uh
so, this picture all what we're talking
about here
uh
uh we're we're we're assuming that all
these events actually occurred.
Uh but we're going to talk a lot more
about failure soon.
Yeah, somebody points out that this
counter should have been updated here as
well.
Sure.
And then this should have been updated
to seven.
Okay.
So,
the real question I wanted to ask was um
look at events A and B here.
Uh so, A has a Lamport clock of one,
and B has a Lamport clock of five, and
we got those numbers by kind of just
blindly applying the steps uh that we
talked about before. Um so, those those
four steps of the algorithm that that we
had before, where we said every process
has a counter that starts out at zero.
Every time there's an event, a process
increments its counter.
Uh when you send, you send your current
counter along with the message, and when
you receive, your counter becomes the
max of your current process counter and
the one that you received plus one. Um
so, that's what we did here.
Um but we ended up in this situation
uh where
B's counter is a lot bigger than A's
counter. Um
but does that mean that A happened
before B?
If we look at A and B,
uh do we know for sure that A happened
before B?
Yeah, so not by our definition of
happens before, right?
Um so one way for one event to happen
before another, right, is if they're
just on the same process line, right?
And that doesn't happen here cuz they're
on different process lines.
Um or one has to be a send and the other
has to be a corresponding receive, and
that's not the case here either.
Or they have to be in a happens before
relationship uh by transitivity. Um but
that's not the case here either.
Um so there's no connection uh between A
and B in terms of the happens before
relation. The happens before relation
does not say that A happens before B.
And so
uh we we have a situation here where the
Lamport clock of A is less than Lamport
clock of B, but it certainly does not
mean that A had to happen before B.
Uh so the answer to this question, if
the Lamport clock of A is less than
Lamport clock of B, do we know A
happened before B? And the answer to
that is a resounding no.
So indeed, uh we only have one direction
of this implication. Uh we don't have
both directions of it.
So here's the trick for knowing whether
one event on a Lamport diagram happened
before another one.
Um
if you like for instance, if you want to
know if this event, you know, happened
before this event,
uh
if you can reach the second event from
the first event, then you know that it
hap that that the first event happened
before the second event. Uh so in other
words, like if I wanted to know if this
event right here, the first event at the
top of of of P2, if I wanted to know
whether it happened before this one, I
just ask, okay, can I draw a line
from there
to there?
And it turns out that I can.
Um likewise, if I wanted to know whether
this event over here
um
happened before this event, I can draw a
line.
And connecting up the pieces, I can see
that I I can reach the event. Um
so but that's not true for this A and B
here. I can't draw a line that will let
me reach A from B.
Uh so in other words,
um and to be uh
very fancy about it,
uh we can say that causality
is
graph reachability
in space-time.
So in this picture, you can't reach B
from A.
So you can't say that A happened before
B,
even though B's Lamport clock is bigger
than A's.
Questions about this?
I'm going to look back in chat cuz I
think some good questions went by while
I was talking.
Yeah, so okay, so some somebody objected
to my uh
uh my claim that uh
that the message metadata was different
from the message payload uh
because uh
if the message gets lost, then the the
the the metadata gets gets lost as well.
Okay, I mean, I don't know um how how
you define the words how you define the
word payload. Uh but I'm distinguishing
between the the content of the message
uh
and the the
this extra piece of information that
we're sending along with the message. So
most of the time in this class, uh we
won't be incredibly concerned with the
content of the messages. In fact, we're
going to be spending more of our time
talking about uh this kind of metadata,
like the counters that come along on the
messages. Uh
now there might be opportunities uh to
talk about the content of the messages
because there are times when the the
content of the messages actually matters
um in terms of of the the algorithm that
that we're computing. Um but for this uh
for things like Lamport clocks, uh we
don't care what these messages actually
say.
Ha, all right.
I've been asked to mute somebody. Um
I will see if I can do so.
Either I successfully muted the person
or they muted themselves.
All right. So
we know that this direction is true. We
know that if A happened before B, then
the Lamport clock of A will be less than
the Lamport clock of B. And the other
direction is certainly not true. Um so
so we say
although Lamport clocks are what we say
uh Lamport clocks are consistent with
causal causality. So this is the
consistent with causality direction.
Um but
it's not the case
that
if the Lamport clock of A is less than
the Lamport clock of B,
then
A happens before B.
And so we say Lamport clocks
do not
characterize
causality.
That diagram actually that I showed uh a
minute ago, this one here uh with the
example of A and B, uh
uh where we saw that A does not in fact
happen be before B according to the
happens before relation, even though uh
A's Lamport clock is smaller.
Um
uh that figure is uh it's from it's an
example that's taken from a paper uh
uh by Schwartz and Mattern,
uh which I think is from 1994.
Um and the paper is called
Detecting Causal Relationships
in Distributed Systems
in Search of the Holy Grail.
So Mattern was one of the people who
developed another kind of logical clock
that does characterize causality, unlike
Lamport clocks, uh and that's called a
vector clock. Uh and we'll talk about
that uh soon.
Um
but this is a really great paper. Uh
I I actually recommend reading this
rather than reading uh the original
paper
on vector clocks uh because this came
out a little while later. And uh
sometimes it's really better uh to read
things that came out later uh because
even the people who invented some
concept, they don't necessarily know the
best way to explain it, right, at the
moment that they invent it.
Um
and they don't necessarily come up with
the best ex- explanation uh
until sometime later, right? So vector
clocks were invented in the '80s uh
sometime, and then this paper didn't
come out until 1994. Uh but I think this
paper does a really really nice job of
explaining uh the need for this notion
of vector clock, which we're going to
talk more about uh soon.
Uh
Okay, so but we're still talking about
Lamport clocks, not vector clocks. Um
So, Lamport clocks. Well, okay, so we
say we said Lamport clocks do not
characterize causality.
Um well, okay, so what are they good
for? Uh why would you ever want to use
them?
What do you think?
Okay, so there's some some suggestions
happening in chat. So,
uh I want to give a kind of a
mathematical argument for for why
Lamport clocks are still useful um even
though they don't characterize
causality.
Um so so we know that this part is true,
right? We know that if A happens before
B, then the Lamport clock of A is less
than the Lamport clock of B. So, I'll
write I'll write that down again.
Okay, so
this is a logical implication, right? Um
we have um we have a something over here
that's like the premise,
and then we have something over here
that's the that's the conclusion. So,
this is a logical implication.
What's something that you can always do
with an implication?
Uh you can take what's called its
contrapositive. So, contrapositives
say that if P implies Q,
then
not Q
implies not P.
So,
we can do that here. And if we do that
here,
this by the way is this means not.
Um so,
if we if we take the contrapositive of
this thing up here, then we get
if it's not the case
that the Lamport clock of A is less than
the Lamport clock of B,
then
it's not the case
that A happens before B.
So, that's the contrapositive
of this thing that I wrote down at the
top.
Okay, so in other words, if the Lamport
clock of A is not less than the Lamport
clock of B,
then we know that A did not happen
before B. So, that's what Lamport clocks
can be used for. They can rule out
things as not having caused other
things.
And that actually turns out to be really
valuable.
Uh it lets us debug, right? Uh lets us
say for sure, as somebody just said in
chat, uh that um that some event did not
happen before another. And that that
turns out to be really useful for
debugging.
Uh
So, we're going to pause and do a quiz
question
for a few minutes.
And I'll post the quiz question in chat,
and I'll also uh share it on the stream.
This should say quiz number four at the
top here.
So, a fun thing about sharing this page
publicly is that everybody gets to see
as the as the responses come in.
So, you don't have to just believe me
when I say how many responses there are,
you can see for yourself.
All right, we're at almost 100 quiz
responses, so we'll leave it open for a
minute longer.
Uh let's uh
um
let's look at some of these questions uh
these good questions that are happening
on Slack. So, um so, somebody asks uh
let's say there's processes uh P1 and
P2,
and let's say that
an event happens on P1. So, let's
actually draw this.
I'll switch back to the document camera.
Okay, so let's say um we have an event
on P1.
The Lamport clock of that event is one.
Uh and then you have
events over here,
and the Lamport clocks of those events
are one and two, respectively.
Um okay, so we'll call this event A, and
we'll call these events B and C.
Um
So, in this case,
um
uh so, the question is
so, the Lamport clock of C
is two, right?
Um the Lamport clock of A is one. So,
the question is we still can't say for
sure that C didn't happen before A.
Um
yeah, that's absolutely the case. We
cannot say for sure that C we we don't
know anything about the relationship
between uh C and A in terms of happens
before.
Uh so, especially because so, these
processes haven't communicated at all.
Uh and these processes don't share a
clock. So, the we don't know anything
about whether C happened before A. A
could have happened before C.
Okay, so the question is asking it's
it's it's asking about that that that
contrapositive thing. So so okay. Yeah,
so so we know
So so in this case so contrapositive
says this, right? It says that if LC of
A if it's not the case that the Lamport
clock of A is less than the Lamport
clock of B
um
then it's not the case that A happened
before B.
um
uh
But that's
that's true here, right? So here indeed
it's not the case that the Lamport so I
guess if the events here which events do
we care about? C and A?
um
So the
So the Lamport maybe maybe we want to
substitute in some other like P and Q
here.
Just to so that we don't uh
get our identifiers confused.
um
So
if the Lamport clock here for I guess
event C
um
it's not the case that
two is less than one, right?
um So
So it's not the case that the Lamport
clock
of C
um which is two
is less than the Lamport clock of one of
A
which is one.
Okay, so the premise checks out.
And that should imply that
um
that it's not the case
that C happened before A.
um And that checks out also. It is
indeed it's not the case that C happened
before A.
Or we don't know that C happened before
A.
Hm, okay. So I guess the question is
like
well
what if C did happen before A in terms
of wall clock time?
Okay, yeah, I mean maybe it did, but it
didn't happen before A according to the
happens before relation. And the happens
before relation is
kind of all that we have to go on,
right? So if there were some way to play
God, right? And have some sort of global
clock for this whole system and know
uh exactly when each event happened
according to that global clock uh then
uh then we could figure out okay, C
happened before A or A happened before
C, but whatever. But no such global
clock exists. So the only tool that we
have for reasoning about what happened
to before what is this happens before
relation.
And
it's and and and the happens before
relation tells us that it's not the case
that that
it we we know that it's not the case
that the happens before relation tells
us that C happened before A.
So if you're if you're wondering if this
is kind of a weak tool
um
yeah, I would agree. Lamport clocks are
kind of a weak tool.
um And that's why
uh we want something better. We want
something that will actually give us
more useful information.
uh And that's what vector clocks are
for.
uh So we're almost out of time for
today, um but next time we're going to
talk about vector clocks. And so vector
clocks are actually going to give us the
other half of that um
of of of that uh
implication. So
we saw that Lamport clocks are what we
call consistent with causality, but they
don't characterize causality. And vector
clocks are
uh actually going to give us both of
these properties. They're both
consistent with causality and they
characterize causality. um So we don't
have time to talk about that this time,
uh but we'll pick that up again next
time.
So see you then.